[Music]
[Applause]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know we're glad that you decided to join
us for this program which airs weekly we
take your questions uh that you send us
and then we look look for the answers
and as soon as we find the answers we
answer the questions of course in the
order in which we receive them I have
with me Pastor David Salazar who's on
our staff uh we have several interesting
questions today but we always want to
pray before we begin so I'd like to ask
uh Pastor Salasar to please have a word
of prayer for us absolutely Pastor let's
pray Heavenly Father we thank you once
again Lord for allowing us to come to
your throne of grace and for the
wonderful promise that you have given to
us in your scriptures that as we ask of
you the Holy Spirit you will be more
than uh content and glad to send it to
us to be able to receive the instruction
and the guidance so that we may speak
and uh learn from your word the truth so
we pray Lord that as we now open your
word you will grant us a portion of the
holy spirit so that Pastor bour and
myself may be able to reach uh the
hearts of the people with your word and
with your thoughts we pray this in Jesus
name amen by the way I want to remind
you that if you want to send us your
questions you can do so at the following
email address tvom tv.org once again TVM
tv.org we'd be glad to receive your
questions do the research and answer
them on the air so Pastor Salasar what
do we have today in terms of our first
question I know know that it's a very
interesting one absolutely Pastor Bor
the question we have today comes from
Kenya and is from Mel and his question
is the following he says my question is
in regard to Matthew
16:19 what did Jesus mean when he said
that he would give the disciples the
keys to heaven and that whatever they
bound or loosed on Earth the same will
be done in heaven I ask because there
have been papal documents and
commentators that use this verse to
argue that Jesus sanction all future
Church Traditions when stating this
please help me understand thank you so
the question is based on Matthew
169 where Jesus speaks of the keys given
to apparently in this case to the
disciples uh that's the question and
I'll probably read the verse pastor B
and that way I'll let you expound on it
the the verse that uh our friend Mel
speaks of is again in Matthew 16 verse
19 and it
reads and I missed here okay the
question the verse says and I will give
unto thee the Keys of the Kingdom of
Heaven and whatsoever Thou shalt bind on
Earth shall be bound in heaven and
whatsoever thou shal loose on Earth
shall be loosed in heaven
okay first of all uh it's very difficult
on a program like this that is so brief
and only once a week to fully answer
this question so I want to um mention
that we have a special material here at
Secrets unsealed uh we have study notes
as well as DVDs uh the title of the
series that I did several years ago is
the Bible or tradition mhm and basically
what it does is compare the Jewish view
of tradition in the days of Christ with
the view of tradition of the Roman
Catholic church today it's virtually
identical wow uh in fact the reason why
the Jewish Nation rejected Christ is
because he did not accept the traditions
of the theologians of the day and the
same is true today of the Roman Catholic
papacy now uh I have also study notes uh
that go along with uh this series you
know this is not one of the more
commonly sold series here at Secrets
unsealed because people really don't
understand the value of it but let me
just read here uh uh some things from
the table of contents MH um the Jewish
view of tradition a case study Mark 7
that's a really important chapter uh
Jesus and Theological conflict uh the
Roman Catholic view of tradition part
one and two Sabbath controversies and
tradition uh Sunday shaky Foundation uh
lessons from two Builders which has to
do with uh man who built his house upon
the rock and the one who built his house
upon the sand uh so um I would encourage
people to uh get a copy of these they're
also available online for free if you
download our app um regarding this
particular text the Roman Catholic view
is that Jesus gave uh the Keys of the
Kingdom to Peter so that whoever he
declared uh absolved from sin um his
sins were absolved and whoever he
withheld their sins uh those sins were
withheld in heaven uh but that's not
exactly what the text is telling us I
know that you were reading a quotation
from the writings of Ellen White yeah
maybe it'd be a good idea to read that
uh first and then uh we'll take a look
at several other Bible texts absolutely
Pastor first I'll read this from the C
of Ages page
413 and it reads this speaking to to
sort of clarify what the keys mean she
says the Keys of the Kingdom of Heaven
are the words of Christ all the words of
the all the words of holy scriptures are
his and are here included these words
have the power to open and to shut
Heaven they declare the conditions upon
which men are received or rejected thus
the work of those who preach God's word
is a Savor of Life unto life or of death
unto death
there is a mission waited with eternal
results so here we just see that the
keys are leading or specifically
speaking of the words of Christ or the
scriptures uhhuh uh you know it's
interesting that uh it speaks about Keys
plural uh in the Bible when you have a
plural that is not qualified by a number
basically means to right like in Daniel
chapter 7 time times in the diving of
time correct times means two times right
uh so so Jesus is saying I'm going to
give Peter and by the way we'll read in
Matthew 18 that he gave them to all of
the Apostles correct but but anyway uh
what he's saying is I'm going to give
you the Old and New Testament the
two-edged sword MH two candlesticks
there's always two because it refers to
the Old and New Testament two witnesses
of the Book of Revelation so Jesus is
giving Peter and all of the Apostles and
ultimately all the church uh the Old and
New Testament to preach mhm and when
they preach the kingdom is either opened
or closed depending on the reaction of
the person to the message absolutely in
other words Jesus is not giving Peter
declarative power I declare you forgiven
I declare you not forgiven but based on
the response of the person the person
says oh I understand I accept I believe
in Jesus Christ then Peter could tell
them on the basis of your decision right
the Kingdom of Heaven has been open to
you so it's he doesn't have declarative
power but what he has is power to tell
the person who has repented that they
have been accepted in the kingdom of
heaven and you know also Pastor you know
adding to what you're mentioning the
actual phrase that oftentimes is used in
there you know in Matthew 16:19 is
speaking of the what's bound on Earth
and it's you know it's going to be found
in heaven it's actually if we read it
you know literally it actually reads
this way and whatever whatever you bind
on Earth will have been bound in heaven
right and whatever you lose on Earth
will have been loosed in heaven in other
words the in you know the church or the
Christians that are messengers can only
basically say or commit what already has
been established in heaven as you
mentioned it's really the word of God
that establishes the parameters and the
individuals that when receive it's it's
reacting to that possibility to accept
repentance and forgiveness or to condemn
their lives for for you know for
Destruction so it's really the response
and it's not the authority of of Paul or
or the Peter or the apostles to dictate
what needs to be done in that particular
case so
basically uh what it's saying is that
based on the decision of the person
which already God knew what the decision
was going to be right that person sins
have been forgiven yeah but they've been
forgiven in Heaven by the Lord before
the Apostle is able to tell your sins
are forgiven um now there's another
interesting text in the Gospel of
Luke uh chapter 11 and verse 52 and we
need to remember in this verse that
there still is no New
Testament so the word key is going to be
in singular not in plural interesting uh
in uh chapter 11 and verse 52 if you
want to read that particular verse it
says there woe unto you lawyers for you
have taken away the key of
knowledge ye have entered not in
yourselves and them that are were one
entering in ye hindered so you have a
key that opens a door so that people can
enter right uh the problem with the
Pharisees and the scribes is that they
uh they shut the Kingdom of Heaven uh
because they use tradition instead of
using the key of the Old Testament to
open the kingdom wow uh and it's
interesting once again that the word key
here is in the singular and it's called
the key of
knowledge so when a preacher proclaims
the message of
knowledge and the person accepts the
message the Apostle can say or the
minister can say the basis of your
decision God has forgiven your sins
because God has established the
conditions and you've accepted the
conditions and interesting enough Pastor
you mentioned this you know it makes me
think in the time of Christ the only
available scriptures were the Old
Testament and they misuse or they put
tradition in instead of the Bible to
help them understand but even today now
we have a lot of Christian churches and
movements and pastors and preachers who
uh only preach from the New Testament
they don't want to have keys they only
want to have one key you know and and
they want to face their whole Doctrine
on maybe just the New Testament and a
lot of people think you know I'm a new
testament believer you know not Old
Testament and they don't realize that
both are needed you know God did not
just replace one with the other he
needed or he gave his church both yeah
and I like to give this example suppose
that there was no new testament when
Jesus comes to the Earth
and John the Baptist baptizes Jesus and
he says Behold the Lamb of God who takes
away the sin of the world people we
don't see an animal there you know this
is a human being but immediately when
John the Baptist says Behold the Lamb of
God they're connecting this with Isaiah
53 they're connecting it with the
Passover they're connecting it with the
sacrificial system of the Old Testament
right and so trying to interpret the New
Testament without the key of the Old
Testament and vice versa because a
serious problem yeah you know St
Augustine uh although he was kind of off
on many theological issues U he said
something which uh which is really
catchy he said the the new is in the old
concealed and the old is in the new
revealed and so they both go together
you cannot have merely one Testament
because the New Testament is based and
founded on the message of the Old
Testament the Old Testament is the
promise the New Testament is the
Fulfillment mhm how can you understand
the Fulfillment if you don't know what
the promise is well of course no way so
so there's no way also we need to
include in this question Revelation 11
where it speaks about the two witnesses
clearly the Old and New Testament the
two witnesses and it says that they have
power to to close the heavens and to
open the heavens and uh in what sense do
they have power to do that well they
have power to do that because of the
message that they impart you know uh
during the Dark Ages yes the two
witnesses they prophesied in sacko
because their witness was muted by the
church right and uh and however uh
during the Protestant Reformation and
afterwards the scriptures were opened in
other words Heavens were opened and it
started to rain again the Holy Spirit
working through the word of God Amen
Pastor Bor that's that's really a
blessing and I think that you know it's
important for our friend Michael to
understand or to continue to study these
prophecies I I would recommend him as
you mentioned to go over the material
that we have as as it's important to
understand even farther and deeper what
the experience of Christ teachings
really helps us to see the the you know
what are the conditions for us to
understand and to follow the Bible not
tradition and and obviously a lot of
churches sadly the Catholic Church main
one in putting tradition and putting
their concepts of um you know what they
have instituted as above or even
superior to the word of God as their you
know dogma of Doctrine and so we have to
uh help them uh understand our friends
from Catholic you know and there are two
true
Traditions that harmonize with the Bible
the problem with the traditions of the
Pharisees was that they contradicted the
Bible yeah you know in Mark chapter 7
which I have an entire chapter in this
materialist that I mentioned mhm you
have the law of Corbin you know where uh
where a child could dedicate all
everything he had to the temple and if
his parents were in need he could say to
his parents sorry can't help you because
everything is dedicated to the temple
but the child could use all of his
possessions during his lifetime and so
Jesus quotes scripture says you know
your tradition contradicts the word of
God because the word of God says honor
your father and your mother right so you
can't dedicate your stuff to the temple
and not help your father and your mother
so Jesus clearly in Mark chapter 7 which
is which is a clear depiction of the
view of tradition that the Pharisees and
the scribes had and which the Roman
Catholic church has today and to a
degree Protestants as well clearly shows
that a tradition that is not based on
the Bible is a tradition of men and you
know the Roman Catholic Church says
Sunday is the day we're supposed to keep
to give an contemporary example right oh
really what did the Bible say is the day
of rest Saturday Sabbath the Bible says
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord your God right so the tradition of
the Roman Catholic Church is a
contradiction to the word of God and so
we always need to stick to the word of
God never the traditions of men and I
know that that verse ultimately Pastor
you know is used to as we sort of
mentioned to think they use it as a
saying Peter the first pope was given
the power the gift you know to have that
that Authority but you know it really
contradicts even what Christ mentioned
in for example in just further in the in
the same uh Gospel of Matthew 23 veres 8
through 10 when Christ says that you are
not to be called Rabbi uh for one is
your master which is Christ and no man
you should call father because there's
one Father in heaven so if if he you
know he's sort of letting us know that
there's he has not established anyone
here on Earth to have have the position
the even the name of someone above one
another you know we are Servants of
Christ no one should be called Rabbi or
should be called you know a father or
that kind of establishment of putting
this power over of of man above anybody
else and I believe that this is just an
example where we realize that Christ
himself is taking away that concept of
idea that he will establish or give the
authority to human beings as as they
somehow have the power in in in heaven
and
you know it's interesting uh that in
Matthew 23 the chapter that you referred
to uh 23 and verse 2 MH um it says the
scribes and the Pharisees sit in Moses
seat the word seat there is cathedra
interestingly enough wow and the Roman
Catholic Church says that when the pope
speaks ex cathedra cathedra means from
the throne his words are infallible wow
and that's exactly what the scribes and
Pharisees believed in the days of Christ
uh uh you know you sit on Moses seat and
basically that was the idea that there
were many Traditions that Moses spoke
that were never written mhm and that
those were preserved from generation to
generation in the Old Testament
orally and so the scribes and Pharisees
they defended their Traditions which
were not in scripture saying well Moses
mentioned that but he did it orally and
it was passed on by succession from
generation to generation that's
identical to the r Catholic view of
apostolic succession and by the way in
Matthew chapter 18 Jesus not only gave
this power to Peter he gave it to all of
the Apostles yes and of course to all of
the successors of the apostles who are
the Believers right amen it says there
in Matthew 18:1 18 assuredly he say to
you he speaking to all of them whatever
you bind on Earth will be bound in
heaven and whatever you loose on Earth
will be loose in heaven again I say to
you that if two or you of you agree on
Earth considering anything that they ask
it will be done for them by in my
father's name for where two or three are
gathered together in my name I am there
in the midst of them so this is a power
to open and close that Christ gave to
all of his followers yeah not only to
Peter who supposedly was the first pope
and and you know it's important Pastor
in connection to what you're mentioning
that you know uh Christ mentioned that
for us to really receive the ability to
be saved or be in his kingdom we are to
not add or substract anything from
scripture you know the words of Christ
are the words of life these are the keys
you know the Bible the scriptures are
the keys to our Salvation anything that
we add as a doctrine that is not in a
scripture that is not biblically sound
it's obviously uh you know men's idea or
concept that contradicts scripture and
goes against the Bible so I think you
know we need to encourage uh our viewers
of course and and my Michael especially
that he needs to we need to continue
studying the scriptures and base our
foundation in sound doctrinal Bible
Doctrine yeah uh you know regarding
adding or taking away from the Bible
yeah there is a dire warning in
revelation 22 verse
18 where it says for I testify to
everyone who here's the words of this
prophecy of this book if anyone adds to
these things God will add to him the
plagues that are written in this book
and if anyone takes away from the words
of the book of this prophecy God shall
take away his part from The Book of Life
yeah and from the holy city and from
from the things which are written in
this book this is a serious thing
Absolut to add or take away speaking
specifically about Revelation by but by
extension it applies to all the
scriptures it's a serious thing to add
or take away from the word of God and
pastor this is another concept of why we
have to be very careful in how we
interpret scriptures without adding to
what it says nor substracting uh because
this is another problem you can start
thinking oh well you know this verse
doesn't really support the concept of uh
I don't know whatever you're trying to
present that is not biblically sound and
by removing verses adding verses you
create this false concept of authority
that is given by men and not by God and
that's why a lot of a lot of religions a
lot of people have been deceived
following the transitions of men and not
traditions of God and or the concepts of
The Commandments of God rather and uh
one last warning that Christ gives is in
Matthew first found in Matthew 27: 21-
24 where it says there not everyone that
said unto me Lord Lord shall enter into
the kingdom of heaven but he that doeth
the will of My Father which is in heaven
and then he says many will say to me in
that day Lord Lord have we not
prophesied in thy name and in thy name
have cast out devils and in thy name
have done many wonderful works and then
will I profess unto them I never knew
you depart from me you that work
iniquity so uh and then says that
therefore whatsoever heareth these says
of mine and doth them them I will liken
unto him a wise man which build his
house upon the rock so here again the
words of Jesus are the words that if you
receive them if you accept them if you
keep them you are building your house
upon the rock which is Christ and he's
not of course Peter but is Christ the
Rock who he can uh certainly we can
certainly trust and build our faith in
you know once again I want to emphasize
this material uh you know people look at
the title of the Bible or Trad and oh
you know it's kind of boring you know
they don't realize the tremendous
importance of this material this is
really important material absolutely and
you know it's available on our app for
free if you download the app and it's
also available if you want a hard copy
from Secrets unsealed and I have a
chapter in here which is titled Jesus
and Theological conflict and I go
through all of the conflicts of Jesus
with the scribes and the Pharisees and
the Sadducees and every single time
without any exception whenever Jesus uh
rebukes their Traditions yeah he always
quotes the written scriptures of the Old
Testament he never says well you know I
think or or maybe it's not that way you
know he never gives his opinion in every
controversy and there are many of them
in the gospels Jesus always answers with
the written word of the Old Testament
not any oral Traditions that were
supposedly pass on by Moses uh and so
that should be our manner of answering
as well on the Mount of Temptation yeah
Jesus oh I think you're the devil you
know because you're you're telling me
something that's contrary to my father's
will no Jesus says it is written simple
as that and then the devil quotes the
the scriptures and Jesus says it is also
written and then the third Temptation it
is written yeah and so we have to go by
what is written in the Bible not by any
tradition that has supposedly been
handed down from generation to
generation the Sabbath is God's rest day
Sunday is an invention of human beings
pastor and this is important you know
Satan can misquote a scripture can twist
a scripture but those that are in Christ
you know uh Kingdom will always say
sound scripture will always base in the
whole word of God Amen well our time is
up folks thank you for joining us for
this program join us next time on our
program I'd like to know God bless
[Music]